[Música]
seguimos analizando el tema que los
rusos buscan el refugio en países de la
Unión Europea con Marta Moya y nuestra
primera invitada del día y es Marcela
chapa Garza directora de la escuela de
relaciones internacionales de la
Universidad Anáhuac Querétaro Gracias
Marcela por estar con nosotros esta
mañana de miércoles en directo América
de Francia 24 también nos acompaña en el
estudio nuestra cronista de revista de
prensa Marta Moya Marta Buenos días
Marcela Yo le quería hacer una pregunta
porque este análisis que que mirábamos
en revista de prensa decía que era
contraproducente que los ciudadanos O
sea que Europa cerrara las puertas a los
ciudadanos rusos porque se
estigmatizaría a las poblaciones que ya
están en Europa o que aumentaría el
sentimiento anti occidentalista en en
Rusia Entonces le quería preguntar si
cree que el cierre de fronteras por
parte de la Unión Europea es un intento
y un mecanismo efectivo de presión para
el régimen de Vladimir Putin
seguramente no es tanto un mecanismo de
presión aquí tenemos gente huyendo Por
su vida no de alguna manera este un
ejército improvisado con poca con poco
entrenamiento militar pues no tiene
muchas muchas posibilidades de
sobrevivir Entonces en realidad son
jóvenes que están preocupados por por
porque este reclutamiento forzado
implica muerte Entonces en ese en ese En
ese sentido el aspecto humanitario es
real Pero por otra parte
hay amenazas de seguridad al interno
porque sabemos que Rusia pues gran parte
de su de su acción este internacional
tiene que ver con los labores de
inteligencia y sabemos que las fronteras
no han sido ningún
ningún vaya no han desalentado a los
labores de inteligencia que van contra
las personas que van a encontrar el
régimen no O sea hemos visto intentos de
envenenamiento en en suelo europeo este
entonces de alguna manera la el la
respuesta Entonces por ahora está viendo
que se va a consensuar es que se analice
caso por caso Y eso implica lentitud Y
eso Y eso Y esa lentitud implica que se
pueda agudizar este el tema el tema
humanitario no entonces este la Unión
Europea siempre Con este aparato con
este monstruo burocrático en el que hay
que poner de acuerdo 27 países y
encontrar la puesta en común y luego
ejecutar esa política pues hace que el
tiempo sea crucial lo que están haciendo
los rusos es decir sea kazajistán no en
en este momento tenemos más de más de
100.000 personas ahí no se necesitan
Ibiza este ni ni ni ni ningún tipo de o
sea entran con un documento de identidad
este y es el único requisito que hay y y
y y y sí que están las puertas abiertas
en casa que están pero el el país tendrá
también este algún algún problema para
la asimilación de de todos los los que
están saliendo de Rusia eh y al mismo
tiempo esos problemas de seguridad no se
eliminan en casa que están seguramente
claro Marcela también le podemos dar
otra lectura a esto la Unión Europea
también puede hacer este trámite
burocrático para ralentizar esta entrada
de los ciudadanos rusos que escapan de
su país para no ser enviados a la guerra
porque no están de acuerdo porque no
quieren luchar digamos contra los
ucranianos no lo hacen También como
medida de presión para que se queden
dentro de Rusia y hacer presión al
gobierno de doblada de mir Putin de
alguna manera para tratar de de de que
ponga pausa la guerra O que cambie su
política se puede ver de esta manera
esa dimensión yo la noto un poco con
menos fuerza probablemente haya un
elemento de eso no pero no me parece que
sea el motivo principal
si bien sabemos que pues justamente los
medios de comunicación están manipulados
en Rusia este ha habido
descontento de la población etcétera
Pero
no sé si eso vaya a ser lo que vaya a
detonar el el el digamos el el
detenimiento de esta guerra o un cambio
en la dirección
yo le quería preguntar si por el
contrario la Unión Europea podría Bueno
pues aceptar esta política de puertas
abiertas entre comillas a los rusos y
garantizarles a estas personas que están
huyendo de la guerra y de ser enviados
al frente pues otras oportunidades que
la Unión Europea pudiera aceptar esta
mano de obra que incluso esta gente
pudiera colaborar con occidente contra
el régimen de Vladimir Putin y que
encontraran en los países europeos pues
oportunidades y unos derechos
garantizados básicos
Sí seguramente alguno de los problemas
es que los que los países europeos que
tienen cercanía geográfica con Rusia
tienen un sentimiento antirruso fuerte
precisa por ejemplo los países bálticos
porque fueron ex Unión soviética no
entonces este el Polonia también sabemos
la historia que que hay entonces sí sí
puede haber este sentimiento de la
sociedad
son un poquito senófobo o por lo menos
no no no no necesariamente con los
ciudadanos pero con con el concepto de
Rusia como tal por el pasado histórico
entonces también implica una
asimilamiento no sencillo
y y y seguramente Europa es es este pues
gran espacio en el mundo de muchas
oportunidades y y donde hay una
conciencia de este que bueno se ha ido
mermando no pero pero una conciencia de
lo que hace O sea no fue bien las
sociedades y lo intentan evitar Y tal
Pero pero seguramente habrá opiniones
distorsionadas al interno Y seguramente
cada país también tendrá que ver por por
en las democracias tenemos esto no hay
que ver por lo por lo que los ciudadanos
están buscando Por dónde sale el
electorado cuando hay elecciones de
cerca y este tipo Entonces sí leer un
poco el el el el el mood de los
ciudadanos puede ser importante no
entonces seguramente si los ciudadanos
abogan para dar Refugio este a a los
rusos los gobiernos europeos tengan un
incentivo más dentro de esta discusión
en el que están sopesando muchos
factores Sí en los países bálticos se ha
hablado mucho Pues de las cuestiones de
seguridad nacional que han llevado a
este cierre de fronteras sin embargo
pues este cierre de fronteras implica
también que estos ciudadanos no puedan
emitir o no puedan solicitar asilo en
Europa porque al final las peticiones de
asilo se hacen en el país de destino y
con el cierre de fronteras está
impidiendo a que estos ciudadanos tengan
ocasión de solicitar el asilo porque
claro el cierre de fronteras no O sea
discrimina a otra gente que puede estar
huyendo de Rusia por otras razones no
como opositores al régimen de Vladimir
Putin entonces este discurso de la
seguridad nacional pero a la vez pues
restringir las opciones de asilo para
esta gente que está oyendo es un poco
contradictorio en el seno de La Unión
siempre no en la Unión Europea siempre
ha sido compleja y siempre ha tenido que
este
Perdón tomar en cuenta distintos puntos
de vista y 27 cosmovisiones distintas no
lo que sí seguramente podrán hacer y
creo que esta es una solución viable
inmediatamente es dar apoyo a los países
de Asia central que están recibiendo no
a casa están este a George ya también
tenemos un número importante de Georgia
Tenemos un amor importante de de de de
de rusos cruzando esa frontera mongolia
un poco menos no pero es esa puede ser
una solución inmediata este y y y eficaz
para contener la crisis en este momento
no porque todas las especies tienen como
este el el el el el plazo inmediato y
luego pensarlo a mediano plazo no y y al
inmediato Sí seguramente una de las
cosas que que se podrán hacer con
bastante sencillez es es apoyar a los
países en los que sí se están estamos
teniendo estos grandes flujos